right man talk about you've been working
man grinding grinding grinding I feel
like every few months we get blessed
with new golf music yeah
I'm just going at it you know I'm saying
like I'm just staying on top of the game
right now I'm just enjoying out of the
benefits that come along with being a
self-made independent million Italy
is there a reason why you haven't signed
like I'm sure I'm sure everybody's
trying to find you Jeff you made like
the conscious decision to like just stay
independent or is it because the right
deal hasn't came along yet Naja's own
independent that's my turn that's how I
came in I got you not me so you know
it's you know when you get to pop and
get to doing a thing gonna make sense
for you to go and sign an area off of
the Nanami we enjoy this money right
quick yeah so we uh we had a Yo Gotti up
here last week and I asked him I was
like yo man what's elasaur what's the
situation he said there is no situation
um I feel like y'all been going back and
forth for so long it's kind of crazy
because you have don't play with your
bitch's ass on that if you go to the
club you're gonna hear the song it's
kind of like to bring her back to back
it's like it sucks to be Meek Mill
because if Meek Mill goes to the club I
mean the DJ's a [ __ ] to play back
the back but that's a big record don't
play a huge record these are ain't no
big hit if you go if you play don't play
if you play play with your [ __ ] you
know dig it I'm gonna tell you what
happened when I played that song in the
club not that long ago clearly went
crazy and the club went crazy but
there's a rapper's looking at me funny
I'm not gonna say no names and they text
me and told me not to play that song but
I told mother like I'll do that I'm
playing with hot you feel me like you
can I'm not gonna be soft and not play
the record because such-and-such is here
the records I I'm gonna play this [ __ ]
whether you feel a certain way or not
you know saying it wasn't God he was in
the club is another rapper
but it made people react to that way
where I context what a rapid air he be
with us on here and all just like that's
not that's not the biz you put me live
that's kinda waiting I got no DJ jobs
I'm saying
like to me I'm gonna tell you how I get
down it like this I walk in the club and
they got a he got some some real [ __ ]
going on with Dom like others is hard
like the people eating others really
[ __ ] like he's dying know you ain't got
nothing do with it well like I mean look
at the end of the day like Yo Gotti is I
mean he'll he's been making music for a
long time he's a dope I mean he's a dope
artist I rock with yoga I rock with
young dogs music was there a point in
time we're like you like respected God
is an artist coming out of Memphis
because obviously I know he keeps a lot
a lot of doors down for a lot of people
never nothing not even a little bit
should know or not is there is there
anything that will ever resolve the
issue between y'all to like a nas and
jay-z moment when they came out of jay-z
long across of G's is there anything
that can that can be done to fix that
area there's no issue there's no issue
now that I know issue is this it is it
is what it is guys never been it like a
no but you guys never attempted to try
to squash it out or talk it out on a
phone call nothing like that we ain't
got none to squash I mean you know the
songs pretty uh it's pretty [ __ ] hard
it's really hard like I mean obviously
hard no more [ __ ] I mean you know
obviously yo so but on the on the
documentary I saw on the trailer like
your touches on the attempt on your life
that happened in Charlotte we're glad
you're here how did you really spend
$300,000 on that bulletproof truck in in
Charlotte spend more money on
bulletproof ear so is that your truck or
did you rent like I talked about
something only one talk about Charlotte
you don't like this [ __ ] over but I win
and whoever whoever everybody else loose
paper right when everybody else loose we
won't be doing our jobs you got to ask
you man obviously the black youngster
thing you got you got arrested for being
an affiliated with rapping in Charlotte
you had care to comment on that at all I
ain't got none do with it don't give a
damn but it oh I could give a damn about
it